Your container just crashed. Again, at 3am, you woke up to fix it. There's a better way.
Three eras, physical servers, resource conflicts, expensive, virtual machines, better isolation,
but heavyweight, containers, lightweight, portable, but at scale. At scale, you need
something to manage them. That something is Kubernetes. Open source container orchestration
from Google released in 2014. Named from the Greek word for helmsman, abbreviated K-8S,
8 letters between K and S. Five things that matter. Self-healing restarts crashed containers
automatically. Scaling up or down on demand. Rollouts, zero downtime deployments. Load balancing,
traffic distribution built in. Secrets, passwords and config managed safely. What
Kubernetes is not. It's not a platform as a service. It doesn't build your code. It doesn't
include databases or message buses. It's building blocks. You choose the rest. You describe the
desired state. Three pods running. Kubernetes figures out how to get there and keeps it there.
A container crashes. K-8s restarts it. No 3 a.m. wake up. Run the darks. Kubernetes. Episode one of 13.